à moins d'une semaine du départ le
tricycle au 37e tour ce que je dois
m'entraîner que bourdin s'organise tout
doucement on est en train de comment je
vais dire finaliser tous les petits
détails
voilà qui peut nous échapper mais on est
prêt pour sa 37ème tour si récit de
martinez grâce à l'habile euros le
contexte particulièrement cette année
c'était plus difficile que les autres
années mais trois cent trente mille
euros c'est déjà pas mal quand même
donc il faut que je pense au niveau de
l'organisation essayer de diminuer sous
les coups sur les dépenses et autres et
pour qu on est malgré tout un super tour
cycliste de martinique c'est un on est
fin prêt pour que ce taux est la
réussite escomptée
au fait on a tous des questions à partir
de le dire
que reste-t-il à faire et bien comme je
disais tout à l'heure à partir de lundi
on va commencer à fignoler tous les
petits détails qui peut nous échapper de
titres réunis au comité cycliste pour
voir si on n'a rien oublié
allez récupérer quand même dans parce
que moi mon travail continue à les
récupérer dans les imprimeries les
autocollants officiel les avait tous les
petits trucs
regardez quand même le marquage des
voitures officielles en fait c'est pas
fini mais on est dans la ligne droite
des choses et d'ici samedi prochain en
sarre je pense fin prêt